cancer seems to be striking everywhere
in our population these days what do we
have that we can help people that are
facing the challenge with cancer that's
a great question uh back at the turn of
the century 1895 1900 one out of 10
Americans develop cancer right now it's
three out of five and by the year 2050
it's projected two out of three people
are going to develop cancer in America
the onset of cancer appears to be
directly related to the amount of of
carcinogens these are toxic waste either
from agriculture or from the Industrial
Waste that we find in our air and our
food and our water and in the dust
around us and the lack of the ability to
defend against these these carcinogens
and the most common defense mechanism
that we have that the one that we have
access to in a very economical way are
the antioxidant like selenium like the
grape seed extract like the green tea
you're looking at Vitamin E vitamin C
beta carotene and avoiding fried foods
and margins and and things that we have
control of eating as much organically
grown food as possible and according to
the medical school at the University of
Arizona this came out in jamama the
Journal of the American Medical
Association December 25th 1996 I mean
we're talking about a great Christmas
gift to the American
people they did a wonderful study 10
years it was a double blind study 1300
people they gave the study group 250
micrograms which is one quarter of 1
milligram and we're talking an itsy
bitsy amount of selenium they just use
selenium alone didn't change anything
else and by giving these people 250
micrograms one qu of a milligram of the
trace mineral selenium they were able to
reduce the risk of esophageal cancer by
71% prostate cancer by 69% greater than
2/3 colon and rectal cancer by 64%
almost 2/3 lung cancer was reduced by
48% with the smoke or not and in a
parallel study from the University of
California San Diego 250 micrograms one
qu of 1 millgram of selenium the trace
Minal selenium reduce the risk of breast
cancer by 50 to 80% and the same study
showed that if you already have cancer
if you take 250 micrograms of selenium
every day uh you will in fact double the
Natural History life expectancy of a
particular type of cancer for instance
lung cancer the Natural History is about
a year brain cancer is less than a year
uh uterine ovarian colon uh breast
cancer is 2 to 5 years prostate cancer
is 5 to 8 years well just by taking 250
micrograms of the trace Minal selum
every day one quarter of one milligram
according to the University of of
Arizona's Medical School uh you can
double that life expectancy just by
doing that one thing and so if you take
the other antioxidants and give up
margins and fried foods and sugar and
caffeine and avoid as many of the
Agricultural waste and the toxic waste
from the industry that you can you will
be able to avoid an enormous amount of
cancer and if you already have cancer
doing other things such as taking the um
antioxidant and getting on macrobiotic
diets and and so forth you can add many
healthful years to your life you can
certainly have a better quality of life
and many people uh will extend their
lives in a in a great way 10 20 30 40
years and obviously there's no way you
can look in somebody's eyes and say
you're the one that's going to live 50
years and so people just have to do all
the right things and they're going to
get the best that can be gotten from
nutrition and the the supplements